Times Square when the 20th century was on its way
in and the horse-drawn trolleys were on their way
out Herald Square not Times Square was then the
mecca of show business and bright lights Fifth
Avenue on Easter Sunday threescore years ago
the plaza at 59th Street and Fifth Riverside
Drive practically out of town then exclusive
and expensive Fulton Street Brooklyn back when
more than one tree grew their Brooklyn had been a
separate City until 1898 and had just become one
of New York's five boroughs when these films were
taken note the horse-drawn paddy wagon this isn't
Vermont its Brooklyn's Prospect Park on a white
Christmas in the era when the jingle bells were
on real slaves downtown Newark New Jersey with
the latest in fire equipment going into action
this shouldn't look too unfamiliar it's the
Interborough subway coming in to Grand Central
in 1905 just after it opened for business folks
were in just as much of a hurry then but it's
changed in some ways for instance it was easier
then for a woman to get a seat from a man because
the women rode in separate cars men were required
to wear hats derbies and toppers of course and
the fare 5 cents now for a cruise around Manhattan
Island not on a sightseeing boat but on a private
yacht that was what the smart said did on a Sunday
afternoon in the days when there were still square
riggers in the slips of the Hudson and East rivers
we've just passed under the Brooklyn Bridge New
York's first major bridge incidentally and we can
still see the Manhattan Bridge in the background
the bridges hadn't yet put the East River ferries
out of business now watch for one of the East
River tugboats the tugs are just about the only
things that haven't changed much in over half
a century long things been sent to prison but
his successors were almost as bad and happens
notorious Bowery photographed here in the shadow
of the 3rd Avenue L was a stronghold of votes for
the Tammany machine during the period today
it's known as derelict alley but in the 90s
it was a hangout for real swindlers and criminals
needless to say the paddy wagon that are rushing
business in the neighborhood and those were
the days when news boys like this lad on a
downtown Broadway corner sold their wares for
a penny that happened journalists were building
a tradition of fearless reporting Tammany was
particularly wary of the New York Times which
exposed boss tweeds nefarious practices in
1871 Tammany put plenty of showmanship into
its election campaigning this scene for instance
shows a group of 1897 voters disembarking from a
Glen island sightseeing boat after enjoying a
free picnic financed by the Democratic Party
from 1886 to 19 to Tommy's big boss was Richard
Kroger these pictures were taken his May and
December wedding to Beulah Edmondson a young
Cherokee Indian princess croakie was almost 60 at
the time boss Kroger mingled freely with the rich
and famous the man on his right his US diplomat
Oscar Strauss whose family founded Macy's after
his political downfall in nineteen - Crocker it
Paree those were the days when a man doesn't
necessarily mean that his wife should hurry
when he told her to get a bustle on in 1910 it
was stylish to wear one of those dresses with a
back sport this young lady has just come to New
York to try to make her fortune in the big city
dum-dum I love my wife but oh you kid she doesn't
have to worry about mashers she can always protect
her honor with a hat fit the fair sex have always
had their own individual ideas regarding clothes
no woman ever takes another woman's advice about
dresses you don't ask the enemy how to win the war